If you know that you've got a book in
you but feel stuck writing it, you don't
need a ghostriter. What you need is a
model. Because the best way to set up
your book for success is to look at
what's worked for others in your
situation. After a decade of coaching
busy experts to get their work
published, I've narrowed it down to six
specific book types that boost
authority, build brands, and catalyze
businesses. And today, you'll learn
exactly which one fits your goals.
Starting with the first book, if you
feel burned out from work and you want
to pivot into a more rewarding career,
this is the type of book for you. Many
people feel stuck in unfulfilling jobs.
And as a professor, I can relate. But
tell me if this sounds like you. You're
about 10 years into your career. You've
racked up a ton of valuable experience,
and the job is still tied to your
identity. You're still a teacher, a
lawyer, or a healthcare provider. But
the problem is you don't have any agency
and you don't like the direction that
things are going in. So what do you do?
Well, you don't want to go back to
school and learn a completely new trade.
This job is you. You want to keep doing
the job that you were born to do, but on
your own terms. Well, what if I told you
that there's a type of book that will
help you do just that? And writing it
can be the first step to launching your
personal brand. Here's the story of how
a single book turned a burned-out
teacher into a thought leader. Anna
Lurena Fabraia, excuse my Spanish here,
her students call her Miss Fab, used her
book to reinvent her career, raising her
visibility beyond the classroom and
building authority in the new space of
edtech. After writing her book, The
Learning Game, she became the ambassador
for Synthesis, an AI math tutor that
spun out of the micro school set up by
Elon Musk for SpaceX employees. But her
life wasn't always this exciting. Miss
Fab spent years teaching in the
traditional school system. Like many
teachers, she got into education for all
the right reasons. But she grew
disheartened when she saw the realities
of the conventional classroom. The
things that the school was making her
teach students didn't need. And Miss Fab
knew what students really needed to
thrive in the new economy. But she had
no power to shape the curriculum. So she
made the hard decision to leave, not to
start a new career, but to carve out a
space in which she can better prepare
the students of today for the economy of
tomorrow. Writing a book was her way of
making that change. But the great thing
about this kind of book is that when
Miss Fab started writing it, she didn't
have all the answers. She started with
questions. Questions like, "What if we
could turn the game of school into the
game of learning? How can we sustain a
love of learning through all stages of
life? And what truly excites kids to
learn and how can we preserve that? This
started off as a list of questions and
it ended as her message and the platform
on which she built her new career as a
thought leader. The great thing about
this type of book is that you don't need
to be an expert to write one. Writing is
the process through which you become an
expert. I mean, think about it this way.
How do you become a teacher? You become
a teacher by teaching. How do you become
a writer? You become a writer by
writing. And if you want to become an
authority in your space, well, the way
to become an authority is by being an
author. Miss Fab didn't write this book
because she was an authority. Before
writing the book, she was an everyday
school teacher. But her career brought
her into contact with some pressing
questions. questions that are on the tip
of everyone's tongue but haven't yet
been addressed. And this is exactly how
you know that you're writing something
valuable. Many people have this mistaken
notion of writing that when you're
writing, what you're doing is taking
these fully formed ideas in your head
and transcribing them into words. And
sure, that does kind of happen. But
that's usually the kind of writing that
we would describe as boring. Think
memos, emails, and the worst kinds of
non-fiction. But expert writing starts
off as an extension of thinking. Experts
like Miss Fab use writing to clarify
their own thoughts and to generate new
ones. This kind of writing is problem
solving. It's like thinking aloud. And
after some time, the writing process
actually generates new knowledge because
writing it really requires you to lay
out your ideas in all their messiness.
And then you start to fill in the
missing gaps and cut out and refine
until you've distilled your message into
its clearest form. And by generating
this new knowledge, that is what makes
you an expert. So if you're building a
personal brand, few things are more
powerful than saying, "I wrote the book
on that." That's why I call this type of
book the personal brand builder. If
you're sitting there thinking, "Well,
that sounds great, but I don't know
where to start." Well, the important
thing to understand is that you don't
need permission to start with this kind
of book. You can just write things. You
don't write a book because you've
arrived. You write a book because you
have questions that need answers. And if
you've already started asking these
kinds of questions and reflecting on
your own work or wanting more from your
career, then you're already on the path.
Here's how you can take the problems you
see in your job and turn them into a
book that launches a personal brand. A
great place to begin is with the five
W's. So, the next time you have a bad
day at work, ask yourself the question
why five times. So, why did I have a bad
day at work? Well, I wasn't prepared for
class. The lesson didn't go very well.
Well, why wasn't I prepared? Uh, I
wasn't familiar with the new curriculum.
Okay. Why wasn't I familiar with the new
curriculum? Well, it's new and I just
didn't want to learn it. Why didn't I
want to learn it? Well, it's pointless.
It's all focused on this test and
standard achievement scores. Well, why
are we teaching this? Bingo. If you can
answer that question, you might be on to
a good book. Second, start capturing
stories on a weekly or even daily basis.
Taking myself as an example, as an
English professor, I have a new teaching
or insight that pops up in class every
week. If you're really teaching, then
you're responding in real time to the
class and you can see what's working and
when the lights are on in the students.
So although we return to a lot of the
core curriculum each week, which we've
kind of run through a dozen times
before, we're always developing new ways
to teach it. There's always some new
example or metaphor that pops up in the
midst of conversation. So each week I
make it a habit to reflect on the week
that just passed and write about a
teachable moment. These stories, having
a database of these stories can become
the basis of your teaching. And here's
why it's important to write about the
stories first and then extract the
lessons. So in my non-fiction writing
class, I teach that an idea has three
parts. A claim, which is like a truth
claim or an assertion about the way that
things are or the way that things should
be. Second, there's evidence and then
there's an explanation that links the
evidence to the claim. But the problem
with so many non-fiction writers is that
they start with the claim and then they
go looking for evidence to support it,
which often results in a mismatch. They
use a quote or a data point that seems
plausibly connected to the idea, but
when you really look at it, it's like
they're taking a square peg and putting
it into a round hole. It doesn't match.
So I'm always stressing to these
writers, start with the evidence,
analyze it, and allow your claim to
emerge from that evidence. So similarly
here, you don't want to write a book
with these unsupported assertions
because then you'll be racking your
brain looking for anecdotes that don't
really relate to the point that you're
trying to make or even worse, you wind
up just making up flimsy stories to
prove your point. So instead, keep a log
of your experiences at work and allow
your message to emerge organically out
of those stories. Third, define your
audience. Now, this is a pretty basic
point for writing, but it's really
important for this type of book. So,
take a look at Miss Fab's book. You can
really tell that she nailed her
audience. Her book is full of references
that'll be really familiar to CEOs, tech
entrepreneurs, and the kind of person
who I would generally define as living
in a ranch out near Austin. There are
references to Lindy ideas, skin in the
game, anti-fragility, which are all from
Nine Taleb, mental models, that's
Charlie Munger, stoicism from Ryan
Holiday, and anti- goals from Tim
Ferrris and a whole post about Naval
Ravicant.
This is a really good move. It's not
enough to just pick an ideal reader and
then go on writing the book that you
want. You want to bend your language
around that reader so they feel like
you're talking directly to them. Fourth,
do not wait until you're ready. Miss Fab
shows us that anyone can write a book.
She decided that she wanted to write a
book before she knew how to write. She
knew that writing is a skill just like
any other. And to learn that skill, she
started working with a writing coach,
which you can do, too. Just click the
link down below the like button. And
while Miss Fab's type of book is great
for pivoting in your career and
launching a personal brand, there's
another type of book that might rustle
some feathers, but honestly, if your
book doesn't make someone mad, it's
probably not worth writing. Most
non-fiction books are frankly
forgettable. They might be useful, but
they're not exactly memorable. This is
the kind of book where you might say,
"Oh, yeah. I think I read that one years
ago after I jog your memory." But if you
want to write a book that establishes
authority, your book needs to give more
than advice. It needs an argument.
That's because books that flip the
status quo are the ones that get talked
about. But this kind of book isn't just
about being edgy or provocative. It's
the kind of book that establishes you as
someone people turn to for insight and
commentary, which opens doors and
attracts new opportunities. This is an
ideas book, but it's not so much about
sharing a useful idea as much as
challenging the way that people think.
So, my favorite recent example of this
type of authoritybuilding book is right
here, The Sovereign Child by Aaron
Stupil. It's a parenting book, but not
really the normal kind. Instead of
offering practical advice about how to
deal with common issues like bedtimes
and sleep schedules, diet and monitoring
screen time, it flips the niche on its
head. It gives parents a strong argument
that children deserve full unconditional
freedom. The same freedom enjoyed by
everyone else. And the moment you hear
this argument, well, there are all kinds
of responses and qualifications that
come to mind. Well, not full freedom,
right? Children don't have fully formed
brains. Well, this book addresses all of
them. And the reason this book is so
valuable, the reason it's spread so
quickly by word of mouth and landed the
author on the Tim Ferrris podcast is
that it offers a real alternative to the
dominant view. And it invites readers to
join in to that larger conversation that
the author is having. This is the kind
of book that readers buy multiple copies
of, not because they agree with every
word, but because they want to put it in
the hands of their friends so that they
can talk about the issues that it
raises. That's why I called this type of
book the new authority. So, if you want
to write this type of book that creates
buzz, builds trust, and establishes
thought leadership, here's how you can
flip the status quo with your writing.
To write this kind of book, you want to
start with the idea that bothers you.
You might already have one on the tip of
your tongue, an a contrarian take that
just seems to fall out of your mouth.
Even the more agreeable and polite
people among us probably have some
viewpoint like this, even if they
haven't been bold enough to share it
socially. So, just ask yourself the
Peter Teal job interview question. What
important truth do a few people agree
with you on? Don't hold back. In formal
academic writing, nuance and restraint
are essential. But if you want your book
to spark conversation, avoid hedging.
Make your boldest case and let your
readers supply their own qualifications.
So for example, with the sovereign
child, it argues against coercing
children altogether, even when it comes
to school. And Naval Ravocond embraced
about 90% of this message, but declared
that he would be a tyrant when it comes
to math and reading, giving his kids
freedom only after mastering those
basics. Third, build your argument in
layers. The core skill for this type of
book is persuasion. So to move readers
towards your view, you need to build a
bridge from where they are to where you
want them to be. So, stories, examples,
analogies, and thoughtful responses to
their objections. Each one of these is a
stone in that bridge. Of course, you
want to expect and welcome disagreement.
If no one could possibly disagree with
your idea, it's probably not worth
sharing. I constantly remind my students
about this. An idea is only an idea if
someone else could argue against it. The
world doesn't need a book that proves
that water is wet. It's just true.
Real ideas make truth claims and truth
claims demand evidence and reasoning in
order to be considered valid. So if
you're wondering whether your book is
worth writing, ask yourself what's the
core idea and who might disagree with
it. It's funny to follow the author
Aaron Stuple on X because he's
constantly sharing the negative reviews
that this book receives, but he's quite
insightful about this. Disagreement is a
strong signal that readers are engaging
with the ideas in your book. Finally,
make it a conversation starter. Your
best ideas should be bangers, the kind
of lines that get highlighted on Kindle
and shared as memes. There are plenty of
rhetorical techniques to help you with
this, and I've created a video covering
31 of the most effective ones of turning
your ideas into sharable insights.
You'll find the link to that video down
below the like button. But the best
books aren't always conversation
starters. Sometimes they're the quiet
ones that solve problems and drive
sales. Guess what happened when this
marketing consultant skipped the
publisher and wrote half a book? She
doubled her rates and filled her
calendar. If you're a consultant or a
coach, then you probably know the pain
of reexplaining yourself to new clients.
As a teacher, I can totally relate. We
have these canned lessons that we return
to again and again. you know exactly
where to begin, when you'll insert a
joke, and what the next question will be
before the student even asks. It's all
quite tedious, and it doesn't feel like
the best use of your time. How much
better would it be if you could just
package that expertise into a book that
solves those early problems and brings
qualified leads into your consultancy?
Well, that's exactly what April Dunford
did with her book, Obviously. Awesome.
April left her career in corporate
marketing to consult with businesses on
product positioning, which is a niche
topic in the world of business. That was
her zone of genius. The problem is that
not many people know what positioning is
or why they need it. And even those that
remember hearing something about product
positioning during their MBA, they have
an outdated and unworkable idea about
how to do it. So, there's this knowledge
gap standing between April's ideal
clients and her consultancy practice.
Many consultants will try to close that
gap by writing a few blog posts on their
website, but that's too shallow. I mean,
do you ever actually read those? And if
you do, how many do you read before you
click off to something else? Others will
host workshops or webinars, but those
are too intensive. They require
promotion, registration, in-person
meetings, and they're not scalable. all
that just to let clients know about your
service. That's why April wrote her
book, Obviously Awesome, with the goal
of teaching her method for product
positioning once and for all. The book
also serves to filter leads. If you like
the book, then you're going to love
working with her. So, she built the book
like a product. It's short, under 30,000
words, skimable, and it has this unique
formatting that color codes the case
studies so that you can dive into the
parts that need elaboration and breeze
through the rest. With her background in
the corporate world, April initially
brought her book to publishers, but
their feedback was all about mass market
appeal. They wanted her to write a
self-help book, something like how to
position your life using product
positioning as a metaphor for personal
growth. And that might make sense if
your goal is a bestseller. But April had
a different goal. She wanted to write a
useful book that would serve as an asset
for her new consulting practice. So she
ignored their advice. And the result was
she became so oversubscribed with leads
that she doubled her rates and still
found her calendar booked out months in
advance. Every new client had already
read the book. Think of this type of
book as part lead magnet, part sales
rep. It addresses a specific urgent
problem your prospect is facing.
Ideally, the problem that comes just
before the one that your consultancy
solves. This is not an idea book. It's a
practical and targeted book. The
solution it offers is your method, which
readers get a taste of through the book,
and if it resonates, they'll know
exactly how to find you. As they move
through a book that is laser focused on
their pain point, they're being immersed
in your world and approach and
indoctrinated into your language and
perspective. By the end, some will reach
out already halfway sold. This is like a
great sales rep. Your book works for you
while you sleep, showcasing your
expertise, building trust, and bringing
in leads who already know what you offer
and who are ready to buy. That's why I
call it a lead getter. It's a short,
actionable guide that solves a specific
problem and positions you as the expert.
So, if you want to write this type of
book, the first thing to do is to choose
a specific urgent problem. Don't throw
in the kitchen sink. You just need to
focus on one painful, highstakes issue
that your reader is eager to solve. A
lot of books will try to impress their
prospects with the sheer volume of
information that they know. But your
goal with this book is usefulness.
You're writing a problem solver, not an
encyclopedia. Ideally, the problem that
your book tackles should come just
before the one that your consultancy
solves. So, for example, if you help
startups scale their operations, then
your book might focus on how to find
product market fit. Once they've got
that nailed down, they're going to need
your help with scaling. Or if you
consult on leadership development, then
you might want to write a book that
could help new managers transition from
individual contributors to team leaders.
Alternatively, your book can present
your full method in a step-by-step DIY
format. That approach delivers value to
low ticket readers while simultaneously
priming high ticket prospects for your
done for you or done with you service.
Either way, the book builds trust and
positions you as the guide. Next, you
want to test your method in the real
world. So, if you're using your book to
launch a consultancy offer, then you
need to be sure that your method
actually works because with a book, you
won't be there standing over their
shoulder to correct any
misunderstandings or special
applications. So, for example, my
consultancy helps non-fiction authors
write and publish their books. And while
I have over a decade of experience
helping academics and scientists get
published, that method doesn't apply to
every author. So, I'm still refining it,
and I'm not yet ready to write a book
about it. The same goes for you. Until
your method is proven and repeatable,
focus on testing it. Teach it in
one-on-one sessions, deliver workshops,
and share it through content. Put your
frameworks into the wild, and keep
refining it until they're clear,
effective, and irrefutable. Next, like
April, you want to build your book like
a product. Keep it short, skimable, and
focus on delivering a quick win. You're
not assigning homework here. You're
solving a problem. So, the goal is not
to showcase everything that you know.
It's to give readers a streamlined,
actionable path based on your expertise.
Think about how good it feels to finish
a book these days. That's the kind of
book that people recommend. So, a
helpful rule of thumb here is to ask
yourself whether your client could
finish reading it on a short flight
between takeoff and landing. But if
highquality leads is what you want, then
there's another kind of book that could
have them flooding in to your business.
Because writing a book is a great way to
build your audience, but an even better
way is to borrow the audience of someone
else. Take Chris Fos for example. Now,
when he left the FBI, he knew how to
negotiate with terrorists, but not with
podcast producers. But when he wrote
this next type of book, it got him
invited onto all the major podcasts, TED
talks, and high ticket speaking
engagements. Even worldclass experts
like Chris Voss need visibility. You can
have a transformative offer and a
thriving business, but if people don't
know about you, it doesn't matter. Most
consultancy businesses rely on
reputation and referrals to find new
clients. Methods that don't scale. But
if you want to grow, then you need to
get yourself on podcasts, conference
stages, and other media platforms. But
here's the catch. Podcasts don't invite
businesses. They invite authors. Before
writing the mega bestseller Never Split
the Difference, Chris Voss ran Black
Swan Group, a consultancy based on
business negotiation. As a former FBI
negotiator, Voss had a killer
background. But when he transitioned
into the world of business, he struggled
to gain visibility. So when he asked
around for ways to raise his profile,
the advice was consistent. You need to
write a book. It's your business card.
But with so much to learn about business
and marketing, Voss didn't have any
interest in also becoming a full-time
writer. So he partnered with the
ghostwriter Tall Roz. Voss brought the
vision and structure for the book and
together they created something that was
really readable, tactical, and
storydriven. But the great thing about
this book is that although its purpose
was to attract clients to his high
ticket consultancy, nothing in the book
is a sales pitch. It's packed with
practical insights and memorable
stories. And it barely mentions his
consultancy firm until the final third
or so of the book. And the result was a
global bestseller that solves a mass
market problem. And while the royalties
from the book sales were a nice bonus,
the real value of this book was the
visibility it gave to Voss and his
consultancy. The book catapulted Voss
into the spotlight. He spoke at TEDex,
delivered corporate keynotes, and made
rounds on nearly every major podcast. I
still remember the year he was
everywhere. His podcast circuit felt
inescapable. Yet through all of it, he
never promoted his firm directly. He
wasn't introduced as Chris Voss, founder
of Black Swan Group. He was introduced
as Chris Voss, author of Never Split the
Difference. All the media attention
pointed to the book, and the book
quietly pointed to his consultancy. By
the time readers reached the final
chapters of the book, they knew what
kind of training he offered and how to
find him. Writing this kind of book is a
powerful way to raise your visibility,
especially if your goal is to get
invited onto podcasts. But the thing is,
podcast hosts are choosy about who they
share their audience with. They won't
share a message that feels like a sales
pitch because that'll cheapen their own
brand. That's why a valuepacked
story-driven book like Never Split the
Difference works so well. It delivers
real insights. So inviting you onto
their podcast will add value to their
audience. The book is built around a
clear compelling idea. In Voss's case,
negotiation is about psychology, not
logic. And while that message has broad
mass market appeal, it also reaches
Voss's ideal clients, business
negotiators, and sales teams. By leading
with a bold, memorable message, Voss
earned the media attention that he
garnered. From there, he was able to
skim off the top tier of readers, those
ready to invest in his high ticket
consultancy, but everybody else still
got a practical, engaging book. This
book is what I call the booking agent.
It's designed not just to teach, but for
reach. It's built around the kind of
message that's worth spreading, and
it'll have podcast hosts and conference
organizers begging you to come advertise
your services. So, if you want to raise
the visibility of your offer and think
podcasts and conference invitations are
the best way to reach that audience,
then here's the book for you. Position
your book for mass market usefulness.
Chris Vos's offer is hyper niche, a high
ticket consultancy for business
professionals. But his book wasn't
written just for them. It was written
for everyone. The core message stays the
same. Negotiations are about psychology,
but the stories, tactics, and
applications were tailored for broad
market appeal. That's the move. If your
goal is to be invited onto podcasts and
conference stages where you can spread
your message far and wide, then write a
book that stands on its own. Make it
genuinely useful to anyone who picks it
up, whether or not they'll ever hire
you. The wider the value, the further it
spreads, and the more qualified
prospects it quietly attracts. Second,
distill your message into one powerful
idea. If you want your message to
spread, it needs to be designed for
transmissibility like a virus. It should
be sleek, efficient, and easy to catch
at first exposure, then easy for others
to share. The title of the book, Never
Split the Difference, does exactly that.
It captures the book's core insight,
which is in hostage negotiations, you
can't compromise. You don't settle for
half. You negotiate for everything. When
readers get that meme, it's hard to
believe. It's like, what do you mean I
don't have to compromise in business
negotiations? I can just get all of what
I want and leave nothing on the table.
It's the kind of book you have to pick
up and read. And when your book revolves
around this kind of a bold, memorable
idea, it becomes a lot easier for others
to quote and share. A clear concept
makes your message stick. And when your
message travels well, then so do you.
Next, lead with the book and the
business will follow. Do not turn this
book into a brochure. In fact, at least
for now, you want to forget that you
even have an offer to sell. The moment
your writing feels salesy, trust
erodess, and your credibility drops. The
reason I love this book is because I've
read it two or three times before I ever
realized that Voss was running this
consultancy in the background. I didn't
realize what the book was doing. I just
appreciated its value. So, if you're
going to write this kind of book, then
keep your goal in mind. You want to
create a sharable idea that's packed
with practical insights and designed to
earn podcast invites and conference
stages. Through each chapter, you can
subtly weave in your philosophy and
method, but never pitch. Let the most
motivated readers connect the dots and
seek you out. Your consultancy can live
quietly on your website and social
media, but the book should stand on its
own. All right, so these past few books
have been focused on business. But what
if you just want to write a book for the
pleasure of your friends and family and
maybe have a positive second order
effect on others who read it? Well, let
me ask you this. If you could hand your
child one book when you're gone, what
would it be? Because of course, not
every book is written to build a brand
or drive business. Some are written to
just capture experience and wisdom.
These books are not driven by market
demand. So writers are a lot more free
to craft a book that reflects
themselves. And for that reason, these
books can often be quite quirky or
surprising. At the end of the day,
everyone has a story. We've all walked
our own path and come against our own
obstacles and found our way through
them. And these experiences are wisdom
worth sharing. These are the stories
that used to be passed around campfires
at night. But a book is something that
will outlast the oral tradition. This
book is all about legacy, capturing what
you've learned so that others can
benefit from your hard-earned experience
long after you've gone. Anthony Pompiano
is an American entrepreneur, investor,
Bitcoin advocate, and US Army veteran
who also hosts a podcast. And as though
he wasn't busy enough, he also wrote a
book called How to Live an Extraordinary
Life. But the interesting thing about
this book is that he didn't set out to
write one. It's just something that
emerged after he began writing private
letters to his children. Each letter
captures a life lesson, something
Pompiano had learned through experience
in his rich and varied life, or it could
even be advice that he received from
somebody else as a repository for all
the wisdom that he'd garnered through
his life. He eventually realized that
these letters might be useful to others,
not just his kids. So, he compiled them
into a book. The book is structured as
65 short letters, each one built around
a single idea. A common chapter features
a lesson, the story, and the mistake
that brought it about, and actionable
advice for how to apply it in your own
everyday life. The reason this type of
book is important is that experience is
not heritable. You can't put it in your
will. Everyone has a story to tell and
wisdom that they earned, and there's no
better way to leave a legacy than to
capture these stories in a book. So when
people think of legacy, they usually
think of wealth. But you don't want to
just leave a material legacy. You can
leave an intellectual one as well by
writing a book like Pomplanos. And the
great thing about this type of book is
that there's really no prototype, no
template that you can follow. The
content is shaped by your own lived
experience. And whenever I work with
writers on this type of book, I really
try to get them to tap into that spirit,
for lack of a better word, that
singularity, the thing that makes them
weird and unique. When we find it, we
can really channel a book unlike any
other. So yes, the content is there to
preserve memory, a record of your values
and your contribution to the world. But
the form in which that content is
carried, the voice, the stories, the
format, the organization, all of it
works together to form a character that
if done well is as strange and singular
as its author and as a gift to your
children, your friends, or to your
trusted readers. Such a book becomes a
precious gift. This is what I call the
legacy book. The goal is not to go
viral, not to generate leads. It's to
say what needs to be said because you
don't want to die with your best lessons
in your head. Instead, capture them in a
book that will outlast you. Here's how.
Write for one person. So, think who can
benefit from the lessons that you've
garnered in life. This could be a child,
a grandchild, a mentee, someone who
could use your guidance. And of course,
if you're writing to publish, then you
know that it will be read by others. But
the conceit of writing to just one
person will give your message a
specificity and earnestness. A great
model for this is the best-selling book
between the world and me by Tanahasi
Coats. It became the cornerstone of a
whole movement in US race relations, but
it was conceived as a message to his
son. Second, no lesson without a story.
This kind of book is not the place for
grand theories and speculation. The
value comes from what you've lived and
experienced. So for every point you want
to share, include the experience that
taught it to you. Third, let go of the
idea of publishing. Just treat it like a
gift to one specific person or even as
notes to yourself. Think of meditations
by Marcus Aurelius. It was never written
to be published and it's basically just
a collection of his private reflections.
He might even be embarrassed by the
thought that so many people have found
wisdom and solace in his private
journal. Now, this last type of book is
more of a classic. It's not designed to
blow up your business or even leave a
legacy, although it could very well do
that, too. Imagine how you'd feel if
your book not only made it into the
hands of thousands of strangers around
the world, but it also changed their
lives for the better. Now, there are
plenty of authors who write a book to
build a business or launch a brand. But
for many of the books that you've
probably got on your bookshelf, they
come from a deeper place. Authors who
write this type of book have often lived
through something important, something
others could benefit from, but which
isn't really talked about. These books
don't set out to own a niche. They come
in all shapes and sizes. But the thing
that they all have in common is that
they aspire to tell the truth. Not in a
journalistic sense, but in the sense of
showing the reader something true and
important about the world. This type of
book exists to have an impact. They open
a window onto the world and show the
reader something valuable. So if you've
seen something that others don't yet
recognize, you need to write this book.
That's what Paul Miller did. When he
left his job, which is the dream of many
of us, he didn't feel the freedom that
we imagine to be the on the other side
of that decision. Instead, he was
dealing with a sense of disorientation.
Call it the unbearable lightness of
being unemployed.
So he started writing to process the
complex feelings he was having about
work identity and meaning. Feelings that
not only Paul but more or less everyone
was dealing with at the time of the
COVID pandemic. So he moved to Asia and
continued writing as a way of processing
these ideas that were on the tip of
everyone's tongue. One great thing about
Paul's writing journey is that he
initiated what he called curiosity
conversations which are free one-on-one
calls with readers. So over 5 years he
had nearly 400 of these conversations
and he kept hearing the same recurring
themes of hidden dissatisfaction, fear
and unspoken dreams. And the great thing
about this two-way exchange is that it
made him realize that readers were
experiencing what he was going through
and that his writing could give others
language to express what they all knew
but hadn't yet articulated. Ultimately,
by writing online and really engaging
with his readers, Paul became a
spokesperson for a distinct cultural
moment in our evolving relationship with
work and meaning. And these reflections
and exchanges became crystallized in his
book, The Pathless Path. Pathless Path
held up a mirror to the world. For the
author, writing it was a deeply personal
exercise. But by sharing it and entering
into conversation with so many of his
readers, Millard was able to reflect
something true that was emerging for
many around the world. Everyone was
experiencing it, but Paul took the time
to put it into language. This is what
the best writing does. It opens a window
onto the world, showing the reader
something beautiful and true. These
books succeed because they're grounded
in truth, and that truth is presented
with clarity and confidence. It presents
ideas as if they're obvious, undeniable
truths. No heming and hawing, no maybe
or it depends. It's just straight talk,
as if the writer is simply seeing things
clearly and is helping you to see them,
too. But to say that books like Paul's
come across as straight talk is not to
say that the writing is uninspired.
These writers still need to make tough
choices about what to say and how to say
it. But on the page, it seems effortless
because the subject matter that they're
explaining is plain as day. They speak
with cool authority, never pausing to
doubt or explain the mechanics of what's
going on. That's the part that makes it
so powerful. It feels clean, easy to
follow, and persuasive, like the truth
just sitting there in plain sight. These
types of books are what I call a gift.
They're written because you've seen
something and they come to the reader as
a window onto the world, showing them a
truth that they could see too if they
just looked at the world through the
lens of your book. So, if that's the
kind of book that sounds right for you,
then here's a good place to start.
First, write the book that only you can
write. The observations in Paul's book
about the changing landscape of work and
meaning could have been taken on by so
many. You can imagine a similar book
being written by an economist or a
philosopher. And while the ideas could
have come from more or less anyone,
nobody but Paul Millard could have
written the pathless path. It was his
personal journey through work and life
that made the ideas irrefutable. They're
not just theories or projections in his
book. They're presented with the
simplicity and clarity of the truth.
Second, focus on the reader's
transformation.
While of course these kinds of books
tend to be narrative driven, we must
always keep in mind that a book written
without consideration for the reader is
not actually a book. It's a diary. Even
if the story that you tell is about you,
it's not really about you. It's about
the reader. Another way of putting it is
to say that if the story works, then the
reader is imagining themselves in your
footsteps. So, a useful razor when
making these kinds of narrative
decisions is to consider what you want
the reader to understand, feel, or do
differently after reading this section.
If you can't answer that question, then
cut it. Now, surprisingly, if you want
to write a book, then you should hold
off from writing because if you're going
to chop down a tree, you first need to
sharpen your axe. Similarly, if you
don't have a blueprint for success, then
nobody's going to read it. So, watch
this video next because it's going to
break down the same step by steps method
that I walk all my clients through
whenever we're getting started on a
bookw writing project. So, be sure to go
check it out.
[Music]